ora tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo vito io sono falli j
oggi siamo su fobia the fear of darkness
la paura dell'oscurità antico non mette
una cag a assurda e va beh direi di
iniziare già subito così in partenza mai
deciso ok
direi che ci sia perfetto cos'è non c'è
un filmato non c'è un cazzo partiamo
partiamo così va bene così dai siamo in
una casa alquanto buio
che bello come cazzo disability qua
cos'è quel investi in vesti gate
investighiamo non tornano indietro
ovunque la tempesta ok si vede a chi sei
rifugiato qui dentro perché c'era una
tempesta sei un genio cazzo perché
ovviamente anche voi capita di
rifugiarvi in casa abbandonate oscure
quando c'è una tempesta fuori cos'è sta
roba sono i comandi perfetta no vabbè
sono tutti i normali cioè non c'è nulla
di strana partita stop che sono gli
obiettivi da fare sembra che qui non ci
sia stato nessun per molto tempo dovrei
investigare nella casa e vedere se
riesco ad accendere le luci perfetto
ragazzi abbiamo l'obiettivo
direi di andare avanti allora qua c'è
una porta si può aprire non lo so ok sia
aperta ma state calmi già in partenza
una sportellata in faccia iniziamo da
dio
direi di andare avanti all'acqua ci sono
scaffali è tutto reja non c'è una luce
porca put di solito negli horror ci sono
le luci le torce qua non c'è un cazzo
questa se dove sto andando non si vedono
e sono salito non si vede un calo simile
niente che cosa devo fare qui c'è
un'altra porta apriamo ok ragazzi le
porte normalmente si dovrebbero aprire
in avanti non indietro perché cazzo si
aprono all indietro
va bè ragazzi mi stai cantando al casinò
non si vede nulla
vabbè io vado avanti assoluto per un
simile como niente tra l'altro laga non
so stesso gioco e lungo cioè non so se
se dura più di un episodio se dura più
di l'episodio lo vedete voi dal titolo
qui sotto scritto parte uno vuol dire
che c'è una parte ii e questa è chiusa
perfetta invece non vedo niente quindi
direi che posso andare in questa
ok questa aperta dove siamo cos'è tutto
uguale sto posto dove siamo dove cazzo
sto andando ragazzino sto capendo
sentite c'è nessuno qui che buio ma
questo chiuso le porte vabbè pazienza
raga volevo dirvi se concepire un
episodio lo vedete dal titolo per chi
non lo posso mai sapere quando gioca
stygia ho finalmente una stanza diversa
chiudiamo perfetto cosa questo è un
bauer posso aprire baule possa aprirla
tipo in skyrim trovo gli scrigni non si
apre per la musica inquietantissimo
ragazzi va bè letto jacko alcuna lotta a
letto no perfetto o cazzo
paranormal cornice che è successo c'è o
lanci ma l'annunciata io no io ho
toccato cosa cosa cazzo è successo anche
del caso è partito era una cornice di
una foto credo cioè non ho capito
neanche dove questa si è questa ma l'ho
fatto a partire io cioè non ho capito me
casse per a ecco cosa ho fatto
e sotto il letto è finita che ama si
possono prendere gli oggetti tipo in
amnesia vai golden non vedo vedo come
niente c'è zero anche questo si apre ora
gas da musica porca [ __ ] ma che musica
è questa mammamia peggio di psycho
cazzoni ma mantico a sportellate in
faccia al comando
è pieno di cos'è questo oddio cos'è c'è
una una fuoco sia quello una forbice
cazzo è una forma una chiave è una
chiara è una chiosa la forbice questa
ragazzi come si prendono gli oggetti
porca [ __ ] come ho preso prima gli
oggetti spiegatemelo vabbè cos'è un
orologio perfetto non so cosa devo fare
qui non c'è niente da cano
perfetto ragazzi non so dove sia aperta
la porta ma non mi interessa saperlo
a sto punto direi di tornare indietro a
queste chiusa qua ci sono già stato sì
cosa devo fare ad haga che la chiave non
si prende e ci ha spiegato allora forse
mista ok ero io che carmelo io stavolta
ero io
ok non mi prendi colpite sono un
deficiente riesco a prendermi colpi da
solo a quella l'ho aperta prima mi
ricordo più ragazzi un labirinto sta
cazzo di casa questa l'ho aperta ma
cos'è sta stanza queste nuova lo sa
chiudiamo c'è anzi c'era un tavolino una
volta cos'è questo è un vodka ma si
sbronzano c alto siamo in una casa
random prendiamo vino e vodka e beviamo
abbiamo c'è la pazza gioia
cos'è cos'è questo è una tazza di tè
bene c'è qualcosa che devo fare qui
dentro di vuol dire c'è un frigo
ammuffita dove la nutella alto non
importa c'è una padella devo
improvvisarmi cooking fabi
ma cosa può fare qui oddio no anche in
cui i ragazzi paranormal pattumiera
anche in fobia che poi tra l'altro non
sono sicuro che si chiami proprio phobia
o fobia magari boh non lo so cosa questo
penso che sia la porta per anno magari
questa penso che sia la porta per i
sotterranei da chiusa ok va bene non ci
non mi interessava andarci sinceramente
allo ragazzi io purtroppo di sotto nei
sotterranei ci devo andare perché
presumo che c'è la roba delle luci c'è
il contatore delle luci si trovi lì però
non posso andarci perché la porta è
chiusa
ho trovato una chiave che sta al piano
di sopra ma non riesco a prenderla e
quindi non so come cazzo proseguire ci
dovrebbe essere qualcos'altro guai dazio
non ci sia di comandi alla fatemi capire
un attimo
beh investigates abbiamo capito pick up
a inter
cioè io devo premere invio per prendere
le cose c'è ma mi prendete per il culo
c'è ma da quando si preme invio per
prenderla roba ma che cazzo di comandi
stupidi e mondo ragazzo stava la chiave
ha forse era forse era qui perché si è
chiusa la porta ragazzi perché si è
chiusa la porta mio dio chi cazzo celi
dietro nello skud non vedo niente
vabbè allora fa che funzioni fa allunga
il braccino
bravo il cazzo ci voleva tanto mi che
invio va bene
fatemi salvare innanzitutto perché mi
pare che si possa salvare si save game
achache l'ho già un salvataggio
automatico va bene salvaci sopra mai
così devo andare allora una chiave cielo
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo
dobbiamo solo capire che porta apre
perché non ne sono sicuro
penso a prà allora io vado per i
sotterranei anche perché altri non ce ne
sono tante chiuse tipo questa che non si
apre per tara ma io devo prenderla tipo
lynch è l'inventario visto gioco non lo
so sinceramente non mi ricordo neanche
il tasto x
come cazzo ci sei finita qui raja le
bottiglie hanno le gambe
vabbè io ti porto con me perché non si
sa mai ma che si apra ti prego se si è
aperta e non so perché sto gioendo per
che si sono aperti i sotterranei ma
andiamo lo stesso avanti però si
richiudeva beh non importa non mi
interessa c'è una sera una bici è un po
ridotta male c'è veramente il corso
delle luci qui sotto l'aspettate danzano
fatemi potere sta roba
ok
devo dar fuoco dove cosa delle acque c'è
un altro madonna che chiave dovete la
infili questa va beh qualcosa delle luci
sembra che devo guardare in giro per
casa e trovare un nuovo visibile che è
stato un fusibile ragazzi fantastico non
c'è stata ancora nessuna apparizione
comunque un po strano c'è forse non
dovrei dirlo però vabbè andiamo avanti
vabbè ho trovato una chiave deve
riuscire ad aprire altre porte chiuse
tipo quest'anno questo non si apre
questa qui non si apre ma come a questa
sia aperta e cos'è dove siamo madonna
che posso sapere io non ho ben capito
cos'è sta roba dario ara ecco così che è
successo ho trovato ho trovato il
fusibile partito un caricamento a caso
siamo tornati a perfetto che siamo
tornati di sotto
abbiamo messo il fusibile sia acceso
tutto che non potevo farlo io dovevo
farlo gioco va beh non importa non
facciamo domande è la chiave l'ho usata
perfetto allora adesso dovrei riuscire a
vedere nei posti dove prima non vedevo
purtroppo è direi di tornare e so che ce
la possiamo fare by così che bella casa
cazzo a tutto la tonalità fantastica
adesso bene c'è un silenzio di tomba
adesso c'è mi dovrei aspettare qualcosa
perché prima non è successo niente
ok direi di tornare sotto punto basta
cazzate devo andare a sono e che cosa
devo fare qual è il mio scopo il tuo
gioco solo aspettare che finisca la
tempesta non potevo cos'è spiaggia temi
perché c'è un mazzo di chiavi
non lo so neanch'io però vabbè cos'è
questo paranormal libro cazzo celi un
pianoforte
faccio musica bello andato va a finire
che questa era a casa di mozart è ok
si è aperta sia aperta la stanza
perfetto adesso tanto mazzo di chiavi
credo
devo dovrei dormire dovresti dormire un
cazzo ci vai tu vuoi dormire in un posto
da ma mi prendi per il culo ma richiesti
e chiusa lavoro [ __ ] dormi dormi
dormi cazzo d'armi che cazzo di posto di
merda cielo non si può uno entra in una
casa perché piove si chiudono le porte a
caso io non voglio fare commenti sul suo
gioco che non ha senso che poi tra
l'altro non ho capito se si pronuncia
fobie o fobia è di nuovo tornato buio
adesso si muovo buio affanculo cosa sono
sti sony improvvisi e chi vi ha dato
l'autorizzazione di farmiga garagozzo
c'era qualcuno maledizione giocherà
qualcuna cose chieco è pif era pif caso
di penombra
ho dovuto accendere le luci si son
dovute risveglio noi siamo entrati nel
vivo del gioco fantastico che non
potevano farlo subito così me lo
tagliamo subito raga cosa cazzo si
aperto lì il giovane è venuto un brivido
cazzo senti zio mi fa entrare senza che
prendo colpi no amica che buio che cazzo
e buonasera si può entro io entro un
giorno ho cercato cosa che cos'è il menù
che appare a caso ma ragazzi cosa cosa
sta succedendo che cos'è perché sono di
nuovo qui era tutto un sogno maledizione
c'è ma che cazzo non devi dormire dopo
la sbronza maledetto e vabbè andiamo
avanti lo stesso era gare un sogno alla
fine maledizione al bagno con la luce
non avevo ancora visto tra l'altro che
c'è una bacinella pace il cesso
tra l'altro pulitissimo ma cos'è
qualcosa ho preso cosa sto cosa sto
facendo mi sto trovando che cazzo preso
cioè cos'erano dei lassativi va a cagare
allora non lo so cosa devo fare qui
usciamo che cosa ho preso non lo so
è questa c'è o che cosa cos'è oddio cosa
che cazzo è successo raga non ci sarei
mai arrivato vi giuro che ho premuto a
caso ho avuto un culo assurdo sempre se
qualcuno non sia lì dentro poi magari
non è poi così culo però va beh
che cazzo di suoni mettete ma porca
chiodi che cazzo qua dentro qualcuno s'è
dato la sbronza peggio di me vedo cazzo
cos'è con un'altra chiave perfetto
possiamo aprire porte prima chiuse c'è
una lettera di solito non le leggo le
lettere ma va beh questa è corta
c'è una chiave per la stanza dietro le
scale la stanza dietro le scale quale
stanza dietro le scale non mi risulta
perché qui c'è un buco non è che mi
spunta una mano tipo in the grudge e non
lo so che è posto insulso devo andare ad
aprire le scale crea questo rapporto di
trocchia e perfetto paranormal
pattumiera ok c'è mica qualcos'altro
detto sì scaffali no perché ormai non mi
stupirei più di niente ma c'è un altro
mazzo di chiavi raga io vado in giro ad
aprire porte e trovare chiavi a caso a
questa è la mappa nel piano di sotto ok
è cosa mia prestar oba non me lo dite
vado a caso che andiamo a caso va bè non
importa adesso vatti a ricordare la
porta che prima era rimasta chiusa a ok
era questa perché trovata subito trovata
più di perfetti o di ok bravissima ci
sia o cose
non so come mai ma qualcosa mi dice che
sto armadio non era proprio posizionato
così o cazzo
cos'è all'iniziatva mattino armadio
davanti o cazzo senti buon uomo io sono
qui di passaggio
sì lo so che sei incazzato non mi sarei
anche io perfetto allora io non ti dò
fastidio e tu non mi dai fastidio
andiamo proseguiamo così c'è una chiave
la prendo ho preso la chiave me ne sto
andando bene vado sa healy è bravo beh
questa chiuso adesso si apre perfetto io
mi chiudo bene ci siamo
l'abbiamo ha girato ragazzi fantastico
da qua c'è un altro armadio che non si
sposta quindi non c'è nulla di dietro
beni raga non è così fantastico che ci
sia un tipo di che mi aspetta cosa tu
puoi camminarci suo e poi camminarci
sotto puoi camminarci attraverso che
cosa cazzo vuol dire cosa vuol dire voi
puoi camminarci attraverso 2000 c su 100
zia ho trovato una lettera mi dai la
mano porca [ __ ] [ __ ] cosa cazzo
affanculo
oddio questo corre agli 8
la ragazza doppio di chiodi trovate
giovani chiamati maledizione ok ok non
entra non è tra ragazzi non entra
va bene anche io ho paura di continuare
direi di chiuderla qui per questo
episodio conti però nel prossimo se
video è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
un commento mi piace anche alla pagina
di facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione sfera zidane con
iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazza